okay i'll admit gladly that i don't like
to drive or cook or get groceries i'm
lazy
sure you can say that but i know there
are millions of you out there like me
who would rather uber than drive have
you ever wondered how uber platform
scales for millions of concurrent users
like us
they must get billions of database
transactions a day i am absolutely
fascinated by how uber designed its
platform to handle those insane number
of requests so i invited ankit srivasta
senior staff engineer at uber to learn
all about it stick around because this
ride is gonna be awesome
hi ankit thanks for joining us on the
show today thank you for having me
priyanka really glad to be here
so we all know what uber is but to kick
start our conversation let's start with
what powers that simple experience of
clicking a button to get a ride or get
food at our doorsteps you know priyanka
the first time i used uber i fell in
love with the simple experience where
you could get a car at the tap of a
button
it seemed magical
being here at uber for the past six
years and the pace at which uber is
evolving to become the essential for
day-to-day consumer needs i'm still
learning all the intricacies of various
product features that we have
at a very high level when a consumer
clicks on the get a ride or get food
button we capture the user's intent and
fulfill it by matching it with the right
set of providers nearby
now fulfillment models the user's intent
as demand and any active provider
session that can fulfill this demand as
supply in its systems
we in the fulfillment team at uber
develop platforms to orchestrate and
manage the life cycle of ongoing orders
jobs and providers across millions of
active user sessions around the world in
essence fulfillment is a foundational
platform capability that powers existing
lines of businesses and enables rapid
scaling of new verticals seamlessly
the platform handles millions of
concurrent user sessions and billions of
trips per year across thousands of
cities globally
we handle billions of database
transactions every day there are
hundreds of micro services at uber that
rely on the platform as a source of
truth for the accurate state of any
ongoing order
job or a driver in a delivery person's
session now the events that are
generated by this platform they're used
by hundreds of offline data sets to take
critical business decisions
500 plus developers extend the platform
using apis events and code to build 120
plus unique fulfillment flows across
various lines of businesses wow all
right so this fulfillment platform it
sounds like this is the backbone of
uber's architecture now let's say i
ordered an uber how does the request
flow work from the driver to the rider
to this fulfillment platform
when you open their uber rider app and
request a ride the request goes through
a series of checks and validation and it
eventually triggers fulfillment to
create a new order for the consumer
this order represents the intent of the
consumer and we translate the intent to
individual jobs that need to be
processed and we store all of this
information in spanner now these jobs
are periodically read by our matching
engine and offered to any open provider
or supply nearby
now we used to store all of this data in
our on-prem database and we recently
moved to spanner
okay so what were the challenges you
were facing with this on-prem database
in this original architecture we
leveraged a nosql storage engine
cassandra to maintain the real-time
state of all fulfillment entities on
prem
in order to maintain some notion of
serializability on top of cassandra we
used springpop to provide individual
entity level serialization
there were a few major challenges but
let me highlight a couple of them
cassandra is built on the paradigm of
eventual consistency in addition to that
in a multi-data center setup it's really
hard to guarantee low latency quorum
rights with cassandra
as uber's products and services evolved
we started seeing complex storage
interactions that required multi-row and
multi-table rights
so we had to build an application layer
framework to orchestrate this operation
by leveraging the saga pattern
but the underlying storage platform with
cassandra being eventually consistent it
often led to inconsistencies that had to
be manually corrected
what it translated in the real world
would be a rider seeing two different
drivers dispatch to them so imagine in
you being out there near your office and
there are two drivers who arrive to pick
you up
it's it's it's bit confusing for anyone
out there as we scaled globally to
millions of active users
even a notion of consistency became
harder to achieve at our application
level in addition to all of this as we
scaled we started seeing uh horizontal
scaling bottlenecks as well in the
overall architecture primarily because
of the way we started with our
application layer with ringpop
this is when we started tracing our
steps back to the properties of a
traditional sql based storage engine
that provides asset guarantees
we started defining a transaction
storage engine that would provide
consistency as the primary capability
one of the things that has been in
mainstream technology was new sequel
storage engines that combined the
scalability of a nosql architecture with
strong asset guarantees this is when we
came across google cloud spanner now so
that definitely sounds like you know a
lot of hit trials and and then figuring
out what's working and what's not
working definitely the eventual
consistency what not was not the aspect
that could be lived with especially with
this scale so what were the thought
process and methodologies that you were
exploring when transitioning from nosql
to new sql when we were thinking about
the next chapter for uber's fulfillment
platform the focus on consistency became
one of the primary evaluation criteria
along with high resiliency and
availability
based on our requirements and various
benchmarks we evaluated
various new sql storage engines that
were out there cockroachdb foundation db
and cloud spanner cloud spanner provided
all the functional requirements it
scaled horizontally with our benchmarks
and provided us with a managed solution
for cluster management and maintenance
now how does the new fulfillment
architecture with spanner work can we
dive into the architecture
yeah we leverage spanner's north america
multi-region configuration as a storage
engine for all fulfillment entities
now fulfillment service runs in uber's
own operational regions which are in
north america as well and they make a
sequence of network costs across the
spanner which is deployed in google
cloud for every transaction that a user
makes
so every user request or any system
operation it results in a transaction
against one or more rows and across one
or more tables in cloud spanner
with spanner we are able to provide a
consistent view of all our data to
internal as well as external customers
so it sounds like uber leverages this
hybrid of on-premise and cloud
infrastructure now knowing that keeping
latency to the minimum is the biggest
factor for an app like uber how do you
set up the networking architecture that
enabled that seamless and lowest latency
interaction between this fulfillment
application layer on premise and then
the cloud spanner which is in google
cloud
thanks to uber's global networking
infrastructure team and google cloud
platforms networking team we have built
an extremely resilient and highly
reliable network infrastructure to
support uber's workload in order to
achieve this we separated the networking
infrastructure into two major components
the physical layer that consists of the
interconnections between uber and the
cloud vendors and a logical layer that
connects that consists of virtual
connections on top of the physical layer
to achieve redundancy
we built redundancy across these layers
by having multiple routers and local
access points at
each physical network route and an
additional layer of redundancy with the
logical connections on top we even
leveraged google's private google access
to route all of uber's traffic to google
apis through the cloud interconnect vlan
attachments
this reduced the need of routing the
traffic through public internet and
provided additional reliability
to validate our architecture the teams
came up with a benchmarking suite that
validates all the physical and logical
network routes extensively and we find
any inefficiencies in this setup very
quickly this was extremely critical for
the success of the overall project
yeah i can i can only imagine how
connectivity and those benchmarking
tests must have been um so so critical
to to make this happen
now you've been on spanner for quite
some time how did the transition to
spanner help what were the benefits
you know priyanka building a specialized
database is extremely complex and
maintaining or operating it is much
harder with consistency as the primary
feature provided by spanner and it being
a managed solution we are able to
leverage a ton of storage
functionalities out of the box this has
given us time back to focus on building
the domain of fulfillment and providers
customers with richer experiences
so i cannot even imagine uh when you
were migrating to cloud spanner we were
still ordering food and rides how did
the team make sure that the migration
and switchover were seamless so the end
users could have the same experience
this was extremely tricky one of the
things that we agreed upon from the
beginning was an internal platform
re-architecture should not impact the
consumers in any way so we focused on
building the technology that would
seamlessly migrate any ongoing user
session from our old architecture to the
new spanner based architecture now since
the data models and database topology of
our old platform was significantly
different from the new architecture that
leveraged spanner
any kind of like migration data of data
was ruled out
additionally given the fact that most of
this data is female and continuously
changing every minute doing a live
migration through backups will only
result in loss of data
so we built a system that intercepts a
request from a user session and tags
them to the world where the user session
started now if there are any ongoing
orders for the session we do not migrate
the user session till the order is
completed
for an open user session with no active
orders we switch them to the new
architecture which is backed by spanner
now the team automated all of this
through tooling and we tested the
tooling rigorously in our
testing staging and shadow environments
we even set up test cities where we
simulated hundreds of riders and drivers
their behavior in the real world to
ensure we can observe the impact of this
migration
now these migrations were done one city
at a time in some cases batch of cities
and it took more than six months to
complete now spreading this migration
over six months also helped us to
continuously migrate business feature
from the old stack to the new stack
there were 120 plus business features
that were to be migrated from the old
stack to the new stack so the overall
technical and
execution perspective it was a very
difficult and challenging project that
we undertook as a team you're literally
changing like the tires of the car
while the car is going so uh i would
yeah i can totally imagine how um how
those benchmarking tests and those
tooling would have
would have been a critical part of this
of this entire migration
when you run planet scale architecture
like this and i don't use the word
planet scale a lot but here it aptly
fits because this platform handles
millions of concurrent users and
billions of trips per month across over
10 000 cities which translates to
billions of database transactions a day
there is a lot happening optimizing an
operating spanner at that scale must be
crucial because you need to keep the
costs low and performance high so let's
bring in preetham shah engineering
director for cloud spanner who helped
uber bring this architecture to life hi
preetham so nice to have you walk us
through the migration journey and the
challenges that come with this scale of
migration thank you for having me
on the migration planning front
there are five things i can talk about
in terms of challenges first how do we
test at uber's care and how do we review
the experience that a rider would have
and the performance metrics so that we
know we are ready
so designing and executing this test is
a real challenge
second is agreeing on migration first
with acceptable performance and then
fine tuning for better cost and
performance optimization
was another challenge the third one
would be capacity planning so how do we
right size and have the right amount of
capacity uh in spanner the fourth one
which is one of the most critical ones
is how do we do this migration with zero
downtime so do do a live migration with
no disruption to uber's business is
quite a bit of challenge and how do we
do it in phases while keeping the lights
on and the fifth one is partnering with
uber to ensure that everyone is set up
for success so for example after the
migration is done what kind of
observability and introspection do we
need in place what kind of alerting do
we need in place the data protection
strategy and the playbooks for incident
management
the key was getting aligned on a common
goal and agreeing where we want to be
by what time and partnering closely with
uber in this journey you're really
giving us truly behind the scenes look
even i was curious to know what happens
what needs to be done to make this
happen any business with uber scale
obviously no pun intended will truly
benefit from just learning what these
steps were and it also underscores that
this is possible to accomplish
a migration of such scale and and how to
actually even get there so unkid i want
to ask you what are some of the
performance optimizations that were done
to deliver this kind of user experience
um as preeta mentioned i think the more
important part was during the migration
phase figuring out what is the right
amount of observability we need across
the board to ensure that we can find
these kind of inefficiencies quickly and
iterate on them
this operational rigor giving attention
to various dashboards metrics and
diligence in evaluating every
abnormality was extremely critical
so some of the performance optimizations
that we worked on in collaboration
across many teams were primarily focused
on the networking stack the two primary
issues that we can for that we foresaw
in the networking stack was around the
tcp resets and the intermittent packet
loss by optimizing the grpc channel pool
whenever a channel is affected by the
tcp resets the requests are
automatically forwarded temporarily to a
backup healthy grpc channel
this allows for the request to be
forwarded instantly without having to
wait for a new spanner session
in a contained environment we saw
improvements of 1.7 times to 7 times
then average 2.5 time reduction of
errors
similarly another common cause of
suboptimal availability guarantee is
intermittent packet loss recovering from
these conditions can sometimes be in
order of minutes further degrading the
overall application performance
with frequent health checks we can
detect broken tcp connections within 5
seconds and initiate a graceful
reconnect on broken grpc channels
with these improvements we were able to
reduce the total number of errors by
almost four times
wow those networking improvements were
sounds like they were so critical to um
this whole setup now pratham how do you
optimize for cost when using spanner at
that scale
yeah we did a few things to optimize for
cost for uber so for example we
optimized node utilization so in case of
a multi-region configuration a read can
be issued to the leader or to the
replica if a strong read is issued to
the replica it incurs the extra cost of
latency until the replica has the latest
snapshot to serve the strong read
to reduce the impact on latency
we leveraged google's private service
connect and we routed the strong reads
to the leader region and all the stale
reads were routed to the replica only
region
this helped us in maximizing the
utilization of the nodes across the
leader and the replica region
there are other cool things that ankit
and team have done
on the latency and cost optimization
yeah in addition to the private service
connect
which optimizes how the traffic routing
works across the leader and replica
region we we also did an auto scaler and
on-prem cache to improve the overall
latency and cost
as you're aware that uber's traffic
pattern is variable by the time of day
and week being provisioned for maximum
capacity at all time based resources
to take advantage of cloud spanner's
elasticity we built an auto scaler that
constantly tunes the number of nodes
based on a cpu utilization target so as
the traffic is variable based on a
constant cpu utilization target you're
able to achieve maximum elasticity out
of the cloud spanner cluster
similarly uh our most of our workload is
very need heavy so we built an on-prem
cache to improve the latency and cost
to maintain the same consistency as
spanner we only route this stale reads
to spanner and we allow our cache to
serve
snapshot isolation based on spanish true
time we built a query caching
functionality to serve just the sale
reads from cache that hydra that is
hydrated by strong reads and writes
wow awesome okay so what i heard is
networking optimization um caching and
also auto scaling
well awesome akit preetham thank you so
much for sharing such a complex system
design architecture and migration story
with cloud spanner as a star
i am absolutely blown away seeing what
it takes for my uber right to show up
reliably it was absolutely a pleasure
partnering with uber
on building the fulfillment platform
which is the backbone of uber's
architecture
and every time i take an uber i will get
to tell my kids that the ride was
powered by spanner thank you thank you
priyanka it was awesome to be here and
share our journey with spanner as a
building block and a redesign of our
application data models we have truly
laid the foundation for our next chapter
where we are working on scaling our
platform infrastructure by almost 10
times and building and modeling many
complex business features and verticals
on top
we are truly on day one of this journey
and there's a lot to do and explore
we're hiring come join us and be a part
of it well now you know what it will
take to scale and handle an application
with millions of concurrent requests
it's not magic it's google cloud spanner
and some planning did this help you let
me know in the comments below if you're
curious about any other use cases drop a
note and i will do my best to bring that
to you